hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
for Monday January 3rd 2017 what's going
on how how's it going oh Jesus
what to talk about first no I am NOT a
father that's not why this is [ __ ]
late all right now I just lost all my
female female listeners I was at the
Rose Bowl yesterday that's why I did not
record okay I watched a bunch of college
football this weekend right I watched a
bunch of um a bunch of college football
got into this huge debate with Jason law
I had before the Ohio State game going
dude I still don't get how the [ __ ] you
guys are in the playoff and Penn State
isn't you know you guys lost to Penn
State head-to-head and Penn State one
year conference championship that would
be like if that the Yankees won the
American League East and the Red Sox won
the wild card and then the Red Sox got
to compete in the playoffs to possibly
win a World Series and then the Yankees
didn't that makes no [ __ ] sense
whatsoever and he starts going well tell
you right now we had a we had three the
most impressive road wins of any team
but Louisville just all of this [ __ ] and
I just kept going you bleed scarlet and
gray if this was happening to your team
you would say it was [ __ ] and he
said no I wouldn't I'd be asking why
Washington the Washington Huskies were
in it like he would have no problem with
the team that his team beat and won the
[ __ ] can we give me a [ __ ] break
right and then what happens what happens
Ohio State goes out and plays Clemson
and they go out and proceeded to get
their asses what a bunch of goddamn
nerds 31 to nothing clemson just [ __ ]
completely dominated them and in the end
law had sends me this [ __ ] text he
said I can see blah blah blah blah blah
and then I just sent him a picture of
Joe Paterno shrugging and said I didn't
see nothing maybe that's what part of it
is maybe that's why they still don't
want Penn State to be in there you know
because at the end of the [ __ ] day
the end of the day this guy kind of
[ __ ] you know it was a lot of [ __ ]
going on in the shower there and the guy
he [ __ ] didn't say nothing it was so
weird about being at the game cuz I was
rootin for Penn State yesterday at the
amazing amazing [ __ ] game by both
teams the quarterbacks they both set
like tied are set on zillion [ __ ]
records the highest-scoring Rose Bowl in
history at one point both quarterbacks
had four touchdown passes which I don't
think I think that tied a record or I
can't remember and then one the the
redheaded kid there threw his fifth I
think it was ran and I was [ __ ] sittin
way up there he threw his fifth
touchdown so final score was was at 52
to 49 the over-under was 53 and a half
so Penn State scored 28 points in the
third quarter it was just a [ __ ]
amazing game and two things bugged me
when I watched when I was there though
of course there's always something that
bugs me okay number one the [ __ ] at
one point they were showing all like the
coaches were one of the Rose Bowl
whatever and Joe Paterno goes up there
and this is he gets a bigger how
important our sports
how important is [ __ ] winning a [ __ ]
game to these Penn State people
evidently that's more important than if
you look the other way as some poor kid
in the [ __ ] shop it's just [ __ ]
it's it's unspeakable all right I just
[ __ ] I'm stepping away from that
[ __ ] program I've always liked them
you know I was still kind of rooting for
them I was like well you know these kids
here in the field they didn't [ __ ] do
it these other people are they're
innocent of all of it and then they show
you know they show the Fuhrer up on the
[ __ ] air
just like I [ __ ] these people right but
then USC and their fans you know USC
fans of the classic you know all day
yellow douches you know what I mean into
this just so [ __ ] hard to root for it
despite the fact you know OJ Marcus
Allen OJ Prix murders look if they put
oj up on the screen you know I wouldn't
have [ __ ] well I probably would have
just to be a [ __ ] alright I'm a Penn
State fan again I don't want the fight I
don't what are you doing it anyways so
Penn State u.s. USC it looks looking
like they're gonna win the game okay and
then Penn State comes roaring back in
the third quarter which by the way took
like an hour in like ten minutes it was
the longest quarter of my life the TV
timeouts were [ __ ] ridiculous in that
game I actually said to my buddy I was
just like dude you know what this is the
most boring exciting game I've ever been
to in my life it was like it was like if
you watching Goodfellas and every
[ __ ] three seconds somebody just hit
pause on it for two minutes that felt
like 10 minutes [ __ ] referees
standing around they [ __ ] reviewed
everything everything but the [ __ ]
coin toss they reviewed like that that
game was like four hour well over four
hours long so anyways Penn State comes
roaring back [ __ ] USC fans few of
them left most of them stayed and
anyways long story short they end up
come you know that they was down by like
I came I was like 27 14 that next thing
you it's 35 27 then I think was 35 35
was 35 27 Penn State than 35 35 then 42
whatever 35 then 4935 that's right then
Penn State I mean USC came back and
scored two touchdowns right and when
they tied it the [ __ ] US USC players
just the way they act their program is
the [ __ ] worst there that's they like
that the type of program I can't stand
like to remember the first game of the
year when they played Alabama and when
they were coming out of the tunnel as a
bunch of them acting like they
crazed dogs at the end of leashes and
they were lunching for it somebody's
pulling her back oh you guys all you
wait to see what the [ __ ] gonna happen
here and then they go out there and
proceed to get their asses by a bunch of
goddamn rednecks red [ __ ] thang
Alabama kicked his [ __ ] it was like 52 -
go [ __ ] yourself whatever the final
scores and then after all that [ __ ]
[ __ ] then they're just kind of a good
game well they just scurry off the
[ __ ] field right and then yesterday
you see when they win right they went
like first of all when they they they
tied the game up you know and I would
say on some ticky-tack [ __ ] pass
interference calls but like USC was
getting [ __ ] screwed earlier they had
a couple [ __ ] it was just sort of I
we [ __ ] you guys twice and then we'll
[ __ ] the other guys twice okay well
balance it out here somehow couple pass
interference thing so when they scored
the touchdown to tie it up with like a
[ __ ] minute left or something dude
all the scoring that Penn State did I
mean they jumped up and down that was it
through [ __ ] USC the guy they score
in one endzone
this guy with no helmet on runs down the
sideline to the entire other endzone
like doing that 300 yell like a [ __ ]
scored even then I would have been like
dude relax it's a [ __ ] tie game all
jumpin up and down all up on the benches
with their [ __ ] Jersey spinning them
around over their [ __ ] heads and it's
a tie [ __ ] game and then in the end
right by the way Penn State totally
played [ __ ] Marty Schottenheimer ball
marty ball I swear to God like every
time they had a first down towards the
end they just written the first play was
running right up the middle right near
centers [ __ ] ass for no good no yards
well we're burning out the way we're you
know we're taking time off the clock
they would do in that [ __ ] I so I'm
actually starve in stat the prevent
defense by the way is actually a it's a
scam that kit was come up with by the
heads of the leagues that is executed by
the coaches to make sure every [ __ ] is
many games as humanly possible can come
down to the wire so people will continue
to watch
that [ __ ] thing once again did not
work I can't even begin to tell you that
just you're just gonna give them the
first [ __ ] 80 yards then you're gonna
play defense in hope that you hold them
to a field goal that's a philosophy and
they will just will take away the
sideline flow the middle of the field
everybody knows how it [ __ ] works and
all it does isn't sure that on the final
[ __ ] three four plays the other team
now has a chance to win
you've been playing defense you've been
shutting them down you've been throwing
the [ __ ] ball you've been kicking
their ass and then all of a sudden hand
up off the middle every [ __ ] time I
don't know choke me up the [ __ ] wall
so then you won us see finally wins it
right after letting up 49 [ __ ] points
and then they score 52 the second they
win it the entire team runs down the
field not towards the field goal kicker
to celebrate who by the way was doing
that stupid dap thing the entire [ __ ]
thing trying to get like a sneaker deals
like what kind of kicker gets a sneaker
deal they get like half a deal if they
just get it for their kicking foot and
the other thing they get like a [ __ ]
sandal so they don't even go out and
celebrate with the [ __ ] the kick a
toe kick the field goal they just run
right down at Penn State's band and the
whole fan section and just screamed all
in their faces and what's [ __ ]
hilarious
is that game obviously could have gone
either way and if they didn't win they
would have been like oh hey good game
Penn State would have done that was just
a completely classless [ __ ] move but
that's how they are you know that's it's
one of those schools would say well the
coach just doesn't take any
responsibility it's just like well the
kids are this it's very emotional tape
they like to express themselves about
this yeah yeah when they win when they
win when they don't they [ __ ] scamper
off the field it's like that Richard
Sherman got whenever the Seattle wins
you mad u mad bro you mad right and then
all of a sudden he loses he tries to be
mr. fight size to be the mayor hey good
game Tom Brady good game everybody's
like that showed class no it didn't
anybody could be classy when you [ __ ]
lose you can't talk [ __ ] you lost the
class act is when you win and you're not
a [ __ ] about it
but anyways haven't said that it was a
[ __ ] amazing amazing game great
comeback by USC and is as much as it
came down to the wire and there was all
those points scored I have to be honest
with you I could have fast forwarded
through the last 45 minutes of the [ __ ]
that's how long the [ __ ] game was and
how long these [ __ ] TV timeouts were
I can't imagine how much [ __ ] money
they made but game started at 1:15 it
wasn't over until like if I want to say
like 5:45 544 hours long it was like a
[ __ ] baseball game it's like this is
this is one ran to the national pastime
but you know what was almost as long as
you bitching about the [ __ ] game
anyways so we went to the tailgate and I
brought that that flat top grill that I
got the campfire one this is not a paid
advertisement dude [ __ ] thing was
unbelievable it was
un-fuckin'-believable law had was law I
didn't want to go to the game he was
having so much fun he cooked so much
[ __ ] I make we had so much [ __ ] food
we had too much food and that's why I
felt like I got hit by a truck cause I
ate so [ __ ] much and made these hash
browns he made this crazy egg sandwich
then we had chicken wings then we had
[ __ ] steak and cheese and we still
had burgers and dogs that we're gonna
try to do at the end of the game but I
was just too [ __ ] full but uh
lawhead was [ __ ] hilarious man he was
so excited to cook right I'm back in the
truck and he's outside of it and this
guy comes walking by and you know when
they sell those ticket holders I always
get one right and he goes hey ticket oh
you took it I go yeah yeah let me get
four so these guys sort of walking up to
the truck and I'm not doing a good job
backing it in because the grilles
blocking my view I'm trying to look
around I don't want to [ __ ] this thing
up and so I had to do it didn't make a
couple attempts and rather than blaming
it on me chase starts yelling at the
ticket guy because hey buddy get out
away with the good [ __ ] party and the
I didn't hear the guy going hey bro you
got to relax and Jake just starts
[ __ ] John at him like he's [ __ ]
arguing when I call and I just yelled
out I do out of Maca exit James
I go do it I'm sorry sorry about that
guy you know he's he's a little wound up
right so we had [ __ ] buy the ticket
hold of things the guy leaves and then J
setting up his [ __ ] his little canopy
thing and he's just [ __ ] he's just
locked in you know
jeiza [ __ ] athlete so he just [ __ ]
gets he he's got that focus right and as
he's setting the thing up like these
four people we've barely even
established our space are just passing
through and then Jamie Lee as I like
freaking the [ __ ] out I said to him
later I said Jesus Christ J I go you
[ __ ] drop the gloves before the game
even started what the [ __ ] is with you
when he's like that out of guys
the guys walking right into each fight
[ __ ] you tired people come to do the
whole [ __ ] camp and I just started
laughing I was like Jake you're excited
to cook say the cookie you got a little
excited then he finally just just
relaxed and goes all right I got a kiss
I didn't I don't know we don't know we
just we had a great [ __ ] time and I
don't know I still nodded off a little
bit in the first quarter you know I
can't get to sleep after all these years
are doing stand-up until like [ __ ]
12:00 midnight get him you know four
hours later I'm an old foe I've really
felt my ages here man speaking of which
there was someone at the tailgate I'm
not gonna say who who was [ __ ]
slumped over the truck cuz they had to
go the bathroom and couldn't so we're
like dude we got to take you to the
hospital we got to take you to us and
I'm fine I'm fine I'm fine
[ __ ] heads up coming back like 20
minutes later dude I feel great cuz I
think I think he passed a [ __ ] kidney
stone or subs I don't know what the [ __ ]
it was yeah so we almost had a fatality
Llyod almost got a game misconduct oh
that was the [ __ ] one on us see that
[ __ ] targeting was never said that
wasn't I don't know guy jumps in the air
he's aiming for his chest and somebody
else hits him then all of a sudden the
guy gets knocked down where is his chest
his head is now where his chest was and
the guy
already in the air right does anybody
give a [ __ ] back oh I will plow
I will plow ahead here I also watched
the UFA I know this is like an old story
at this point but uh you know everybody
like everybody else I watched the
amended Nunez and the Ronda Rousey
rowdy Ronda Rousey fight and yeah that
was tough to watch that was definitely
tough to watch and it was even tougher
to watch all the [ __ ] [ __ ] talking
[ __ ] on like Twitter and all the
memes you know [ __ ] uh you know I've
taken that plug in the know they went to
get a drink and then it was [ __ ] over
and it's just like like all of these
people have have fought and competed and
won in the Octagon and they have the
right to talk [ __ ] like that it's just I
don't know why people do stuff like that
you know if that happens to every
champion if they stay if they stick
around eventually somebody younger he's
gonna you're the champ everybody's
breaking down what the [ __ ] it is you do
over and over and over and over again
and then eventually you get run down it
happens to everybody if it could happen
to Muhammad Ali Sugar Ray Leonard Marvin
Hagler all these [ __ ] guys their last
fight I saw him loose Roy Jones jr. Matt
huge George st. Pierre right I think
George st. Pierre might have won his
last one but he was all beat up and
everything but and said he didn't
remember part of the fight so that's
what happens to everybody so of course I
text this to my buddy he goes well not
Rocky or [ __ ] mayweather meaning
Rocky Marciano and it's just like dude
alright Rocky Marciano absolutely but
like Mayweather I don't know mayweather
owes me like 300 bucks in pay-per-view I
think about that guy
alright I'm really going out on a limb
here cuz I don't watch that much boxing
I think one obviously one of the
greatest fighters of all [ __ ] time
but like he's just also understood that
final third of his career I feel better
than anybody else how do you still
continue fighting and not take that big
[ __ ] knock down part of it or balana
part was his amazing defense but the
other is the [ __ ] opponent's that he
picked you
I mean that [ __ ] Pacquiao fight
should have happened at least eight
years before I was on his side where I
was like yeah maybe he's on drugs
he probably I don't know maybe is maybe
[ __ ] isn't but I don't know all the
know boxing isn't the way it was
somewhere in the 80s it died like that
Hagler Hearns Duran Leonard they all
lost and they all [ __ ] lost to each
other and [ __ ] it's just like you had
unbelievable fighters for unbelievable
fighters and they all fought each other
it's impossible to stay undefeated but
you know when you [ __ ] it you know it'd
be like if Jeff [ __ ] Ali [ __ ] Jill
finally fought Joe Frazier in like 1981
like when Ali's last fights I think was
against Larry Holmes who then was the
[ __ ] champ for like the next four
years or whatever his rule until I think
Tyson came along or maybe there's one
guy in between I can't remember it's
been so long ago Hagler's last loss was
to Sugar Ray Leonard I mean these guys
fought champions right up until he ended
their career as opposed to you know
fighting some guy from England with
weight issues you know that one Ricky
Ricky Ricky Hatton I saw that fight I
don't like talking [ __ ] about fighters
either because they you know they can
all beat the [ __ ] out of me I'm just
saying that you know I think it's gonna
hurt mayweather the level of guy that he
fought in the final third of his career
because I know for one like just I just
you know he'd watch his [ __ ] fights
the other guy couldn't hit him
Mayweather couldn't knock him out and he
just kind of puh-puh-puh the whole
[ __ ] fight with his those white
kitten gloves fight not to lose playing
not playing not to lose like Penn State
like Penn State did in the fourth
[ __ ] quarter so that's I don't that's
my own dumb opinion I don't what I don't
know [ __ ] about fighting but all I know
this is your [ __ ] [ __ ]
if you go on Twitter and you start
trashing somebody because they because
they got knocked out like they're a
[ __ ]
or you are overrated or any of that type
of
[ __ ] I mean some of you probably say I
just did that to Mayweather I'm not I'm
saying he's one of the greatest of all
time I would never say that the guy's a
[ __ ] or anything like that I would have
just liked to watch him fight a better
caliber fighter I don't know you know I
mean I'd like that that Mayweather
Pacquiao fight that should have [ __ ]
happened in 105 oh six something like
that bill shut the [ __ ] all right I'll
shut the [ __ ] up anyways um you know
what it really is is that virzi [ __ ]
said that Mayweather would have [ __ ]
beat Hagler Hearns leonard durant like
he would have [ __ ] beat all of him
it's like he would it be all of them all
of them couldn't beat all of each other
you know I don't know what he's I don't
know what he's basing it on you know
what he's basing it on he's basing it on
being born in the late 70s I just you
know I'm just an old [ __ ] crabby man
speaking of which you know I've been
working on my anger I got in the car
today to return the pickup truck and I I
[ __ ] I don't know I made it down the
street or around the block before I got
into an argument with this [ __ ] woman
who just glided through her stop sign in
her white Mercedes Benz I got a [ __ ]
I got a thing anybody who's got a white
Mercedes a white people white cars man
high-end white cars are [ __ ] is
entitled [ __ ] I don't like them you
don't I mean they think the cars are
classy right I always give Rosie [ __ ]
like virzi loves a white car you know
they just think it's the classiest
[ __ ] thing ever
Mercedes and BMW they've really fallen
the [ __ ] off you know what I mean they
just went right down to the bottom
feeders anybody with likes who can
afford 60 bucks a month can lease one of
those cars now I'm telling you when he
used to see a Mercedes drive down the
street
used to be some [ __ ] guy like in his
50s who was wealthy or if a BMW even
then that was like more like the yuppie
guy like I'm not having [ __ ] kids and
I'll pour [ __ ] in the drinking water
just to make another buck you know
the [ __ ] stock market banker psycho
right we would just have it rough sex
you know that [ __ ] lunatic now it's
like it's like [ __ ] 21-year old kids
I think this podcast should just be like
some sort of theme of like things aren't
the way they used to be and I'm [ __ ]
upset about it you know what it is is I
didn't have a good breakfast today and
at my age that's not a good thing you
know I woke up and we didn't have any
[ __ ] real food the [ __ ] my frying
pan was underneath all this dirty [ __ ]
from the [ __ ] Rose Bowl that's in the
sink is like I'm not gonna fry up a
[ __ ] egg and Nia has one of those
[ __ ] little kids cereals in there and
I was just like all right I'll [ __ ]
hate this [ __ ] and um I already had the
[ __ ] sugar high and now I'm starting
to crash so I'm being I'm being a little
harsh on the Millennials you know in
Floyd Mayweather and people who drive
white cars I mean I can omit that in
2017 I can admit that this is the new me
the new Bill I meditate now and by
saying I meditate means I tried it once
last week and I plan on doing it twice a
day
but I've only done it once so far but uh
but I've been thinking about doing it
you know and people mints enemies [ __ ]
about trying to get over my [ __ ]
anger issues and yeah that lady like
glided through the stop sign and I just
stopped it so you got a stop sign right
then she goes you got one over there and
I go that's not it it's the other ones
it's just like you're just a [ __ ]
another douche in a white Mercedes I
swear to God
do you think if they stopped making that
car people would drive better if there's
something about people and then they get
in a white Mercedes a white [ __ ] car
like you know of up that cost a certain
amount of money that's it look I'm
getting upset again
just relax bill take a [ __ ] breath
you know go outside look at the birds
whatever the hell it is you're supposed
to do you know somebody sent me this I
got I should play it now somebody sent
me this [ __ ] video on you know how to
get over my anger and at the risk of
sounding like a hack comedian it
actually it
make me angry he'd [ __ ] upset me
though it really didn't let me see this
here see if I can click on this [ __ ]
thing again
oh how not to be angry all the time I
wonder if I can play this and not get
[ __ ] trouble by some some podcasting
entity here see if I can turn this
[ __ ] thing up here so I look at this
thing right it's a cartoon
so immediately it's on my intellect
level right here it is this this is what
they're trying to say to me I'll try to
play this here my minimal [ __ ]
abilities here oh for God's sakes are
you gonna play it here or what I hit
play I refuse to get [ __ ] angry
during this point why won't this thing
play oh I know cuz I'm in this room I'm
in this room so the [ __ ] in the
internet doesn't work oh there's a
little spin wheel it's gradually fights
spinning around what's gonna happen all
I want to do is play this [ __ ] all I
want to do Romo zoom zoom zoom I just
want to play this [ __ ] video how does
it know how does the universe know when
you're trying to [ __ ] do something
all right you know what [ __ ] I'm not
playing Hey look at that I'm not angry
anymore cuz I just gave in because
that's basically what this [ __ ] video
told you to do it was talking about
so-and-so disease this is the name of
the video it says how not to be angry
all the time and I would love to read
the [ __ ] comments on this thing right
he says how not to be angry all the time
and it shows this guy it's like William
oh I think it's actually the name was
Bill I can't remember you know he likes
to read the newspaper and he tells his
wife not to interrupt him while he's
doing that and then it goes his wife
finds this very upsetting so one time
he's reading the newspaper and she says
hey what are you gonna you know set the
table the blah blah blah and William
flips out he gets angry and it says
William gets angry because he has hope
it was talking about how angry people as
much as they come off as they're
negative they're actually really
positive people and was basically saying
that they have hope so they present all
these different scenarios and they're
like at each one of these cell you
he goes to the airport and his plane is
delayed he's one of the premier [ __ ]
flyers he gets mad he goes up he flips
he screams at the [ __ ] lady behind the
counter because he is hopeful and it was
basically saying that he needed to be a
little more pessimistic oh it's a video
here's a video it's basically saying you
needed to be a negative [ __ ] there we go
why is it so [ __ ] quiet you know what
I can't deal with this [ __ ] guy's
accent I can't deal with it oh I know I
had to I had the [ __ ] microphone turn
around there we go do you meet people
they actually types
we certainly don't usually think of them
as optimists I can't [ __ ] oh my god I
can't [ __ ] listen to it Kenny why is
he gonna [ __ ] it over that's everything
and not see yet everything gloomy people
actually positively people on the deck
yeah so basically he goes through all of
this [ __ ] [ __ ] right and he says in
in to be more positive is what you have
to do is you have to accept the world
that the world is actually a very dark
gloomy place and most things fail and
most basically most dreams don't come
true and you know be more of like a
realist and like people who you know
people get upset people who aren't angry
people get upset when something happens
but they get over it way quicker and
they don't get nearly as mad and it's
basically because I guess they're
walking around going like oh yeah why
wouldn't this person in this white
Mercedes blow through the stop sign of
course they do I guess this part of me I
understand that like I flip out about
the [ __ ] drivers out here and I
literally say to myself out loud after I
flip
in the car going like yes bill you have
established that people out here suck at
driving when are you gonna stop reacting
to it and you know III don't think ever
I don't think it's because I'm like an
optimist I don't have I'm not hopeful
that someone [ __ ] you know if they're
going to make a left that they that
they'll get all the way over to the left
instead of sitting in the middle of the
lane and now I have to [ __ ] wait
where if you just were over by the
double yellow line I could have gone
around you you [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm not like
hopeful that they're gonna do that I
don't have like hope that they're gonna
do it I just can't understand why you
wouldn't because I know that person has
been sitting behind somebody doing that
it's like when you're you're in a long
line and [ __ ] whatever and it's
moving slow and everybody's yeah more
and what the person on the other side of
the [ __ ] desk it's like she's get up
there say what you want shut the [ __ ] up
how hard is that
and there'll be a person in front look
at you rolling their eyes like I can't
believe how long this takes and then
they get up there what are they does
[ __ ] launch into all of this [ __ ]
that is nothing to do with what you're
doing and it's just [ __ ] adds time so
I'm not I don't have any hope that
people are gonna maybe I do I hope you
know I guess I would hope you'd be a
[ __ ] not a [ __ ]
and figure out why this seems to be
taking way longer than it should I don't
know I don't think it's cuz I have hope
I think well the reason why I get
[ __ ] angry is because that is my
default emotion I think that that's what
it is
you know I came for in those families I
got one of those things which you know
if you're not allowed to express
yourself you immediately feel like
you're not gonna get what you want in
life and I think that that's what I
think that's why I flip up you know I
flip out because of that like you know
if something starts to go away I don't
want it to go no one's gonna listen to
me and I
don't have any [ __ ] options other
than just sit there and [ __ ] take it
so I think that's why I don't think it's
cuz I'm hopeful I get maybe a little bit
baby I'm such an angry [ __ ] I can't say
that there's some truth in this video
but I don't think the solution is is to
just walk around you know just accepting
that people are the way that they are
you know that'd be like if you know
you're coaching a team and be like yeah
you know we're eight Nate
yeah we're just eight Nate yeah next
year you know I will probably eight Nate
again cuz I've accepted that this is the
way things are I know a lot of positive
driven people and they're not angry
people so I don't think being positive
is part of that I think it's I think
it's just time I [ __ ] wires my mental
wires have been soldered together I
think I probably came into the world I
don't know can you come into the world
angry I don't know I don't think you can
I don't think you're born that [ __ ]
way I have no [ __ ] idea but I don't
know about this video where I gonna now
just I just the solution is just to be
like yeah well you know people out here
when they make laughs that's how they're
gonna do it I mean I guess if you just
do that then you don't get angry because
all these years of me getting angry has
not made people stop doing that it never
made the person in front of me go like
oh I'm sorry let me get over they just
sort of look at me weird as I as I Drive
by yelling at them looking at me like
what the [ __ ] is he yelling at me am i
doing something I have no I have in the
wrong I don't know I have no idea I
think I don't know I don't know what my
deal is but I plan on getting to the
bottom but at least understand it but I
don't think a three-minute [ __ ]
YouTube video with some guy with his
[ __ ] you know I think in the United
States we like getting like people with
English accents to [ __ ] narrate shake
is that it just sounds like it's true or
smart you don't I mean we
why I think all these these English guys
have been Scottish guys have done well
maybe it's just women like [ __ ] that
accent or just like a different foreign
accent I don't know like these talk show
people you know for some reason that
slot that used to be after David
Letterman you have to get an English or
a Scottish guy like that's become like
that time slot like an American accented
guy cannot do well in that that is the
Great Britain accent time slot I don't
know but I I all I know is I can't
listen to [ __ ] I can't listen to this
again he's a friend he's often furious
he's he's often furious he sounds like
he's in the [ __ ] Clockwork Orange but
I am off often furious his name was Fred
I know it was one of my names right all
right what am I doing here let's let's
let's read some [ __ ] advertising here
thirty four [ __ ] minutes into this
podcast and I don't think I'm I don't
think I'm even remotely a better person
what about you guys
alright oh it's our friends here no wait
let's let's let's stay on this point
here maybe maybe that's what I should
I'm gonna try that today I'm gonna just
try walking around and what I'm gonna do
is have my eyebrows up a little bit I'm
gonna do that thing that people do you
know where they make their lips
disappear their mouth looks like it's
closed but their lips disappear you know
the Carlton I'm just gonna do that walk
around the kind of course this thing
that should take 90 seconds of course
now it's gonna take six minutes mm-hm
yep okay take my car over to the
dealership to get the the brake light
done I mean I know that I could change
out a brake light but of course you have
the screws there they're inside the car
behind a plastic thing and I know when I
go to take that thing off that there the
head on the screw is going to be
something I've never seen before and
requests and requires a special
screwdriver that I could go down or
maybe order on Amazon you know and of
course they won't just sell me the one
I'll have to buy the whole set and then
I'll be like well I guess I can pay
[ __ ] $35 for a new set of
screwdrivers and hope I don't get a
ticket over the next few [ __ ] days or
I could just drive down to the [ __ ]
dealership and just pay a hundred and
eighty bucks for a [ __ ] like got
Murray get Madigan I'm just gonna go
down to the dealership and just say yes
I have something that I could totally
repair on my car if you guys hadn't put
those alien screws in there excuse me
could I have the screwdriver that I need
to undo those four screws could I could
I have that please and could I then find
the corporate guy right as he's getting
on his jet who came up with this idea
and could I please just I don't know
just sort of stick it into the side of
his neck I think that would be nice
how does that work if I say angry [ __ ]
but I say it in a pleasant way ma'am is
there a reason why you're so not focused
as you work this cash register is there
a reason why you feel that you're above
a job that you stink at how does that
work
shouldn't you be so good at this job
that I'm actually sitting there thinking
to myself why are you working here
you're way beyond this why are you
standing here
reinforcing that you're not even good
enough to do this job because you think
you're better than another job is there
any way you could open that cash
register door and I could grab you by
your ponytail shove your head into the
drawer and then see how far I could
close it with your head in it is there a
way I could do that sorry guys you just
know I have to rehearse everything that
I'm gonna go through today oh hello
staples no you cannot you cannot have my
phone number I mean I'll give you a
phone number and I will give you an
alternate phone number yes I will none
of these will be true oh I'll give you a
give you a you know my fake email
addresses that I give it's you know it
at aol.com
you gotta have a fake one you know it at
aol.com
that's my fake one and that is a
reference to Will Ferrell in old school
Frank the tank when they go Frank the
tank Frankie's going you know it you
know it the fake phone number I give out
is a series of area codes followed by
the number of five they'll be like
what's your uh what's your phone number
it's like three two three two one two
eight one eight five that's what I do
well they start to look at you after two
area codes you know when you go like
three one oh two one two they get that
you get that little puppy look the
little [ __ ] in the head and then rather
than saying eight one eight cuz they're
gonna know I go eight one eight five so
I still get it in their fake name I go
with all the time Russell Russell
whenever I just need a first name what's
your name hey what's your name Russell
Russell what can I do for you today well
you can yeah you can start by not asking
me personal questions all right that's
what you can do and you can get some
loafers that are that fit your [ __ ]
feet how about that all right did tight
shoes I'm sorry
I know what to say oh by the way I you
know I got some video my old buddy Cleo
and she seems happy as hell and this is
unprecedented this person that I gave my
dog to is a dog trainer and at like the
[ __ ] dog whisperer level so which is
what my dog needed and he sent me video
of something I've never seen before my
dog came in and wanted to play with
another dog which my dog never did my
dog tried to kill other dogs my dog
tried to kill another dog when my dog
was with the trainer that now has it and
he slowly been working with this [ __ ]
thing and was amazing and the trainer
said you know within a week to ten days
they will probably be just like best of
friends
sleeping together in the Sun
so that made me feel good cuz I think
she's actually happier in that
environment than she was with me even
though you know I miss her to death or
what but that made me feel good so there
you go there you go I'll tell you that
[ __ ] dog is at an amazing life an
amazing life like literally it should
have been over like three different
times and it always survives and it's
life has gotten progressively better so
that made me feel good as much as I as
much as I miss the thing that's cool
it's got a friend alright
oh here we go let's tree a little
advertising here Oh zip are you high
you're in hey do you know where to post
your job to find the best candidates
posting jobs in one place isn't enough
to find quality candidates oh you you
want to find the perfect high you need
to post your job on all the sites Joe
and now you can with zip recruiter calm
you can post your job to 100 plus job
sites including social media networks
like Facebook and [ __ ] and all with a
single click find candidates in any city
or industry nationwide just post once
and watch your qualified candidates roll
into zip recruiters easy to use
interface no juggling emails or calls to
your office quickly screen candidates
write them and hire the right person
fast find out today why zip com zip
recruit has been used by over 1 million
businesses and right now my listeners
can post job on zip cruder for free by
going to zip recruit accom / / that's
zip recruit accom / / one more time hey
try it for free go to zip dot-com / burp
oh give me the loot loot crate everybody
hey nerds listen up
put down you [ __ ] devil dog quit
licking the sides like a creep all right
be the envy of your friends and get your
100% exclusive crates at Luke Craig calm
/ / and enter my code Barbie you are are
to save three dollars off any new
subscription wait until I tell you all
wait until I tell you about January's
crate it'll take you back to the old
school you know alright copy points
mention at least three times a spot I
don't get like today but maybe I think
these ads are so [ __ ] long cuz I read
everything coffee mentioned at least
three times his spot mention what why
don't you write what the [ __ ] I'm
supposed to be on you know it'd be nice
if you guys would just write down when
I'm supposed to mention and then I don't
have to do the math than the copy I
would really appreciate that okay Luke
rape you [ __ ] [ __ ] alright Luke rate
offers an epic range of pop-culture
items for less than $20 a month
what are give me a key change less than
$20 a month I sounds like a bunch of
[ __ ] if you're more of an attic
fashionista then try loot where oh here
we go here's where you start spending
your money monthly wearables and
accessories with cult classics and your
favorite franchises if you want to get
fancy get a bigger box with even bigger
loot with loot crate DX this offer
expires January 19th at 9 p.m. Pacific
get ready for January old school thing
origins everybody origins loot crate has
awesome and exclusive items from your
old school favorites can you just
[ __ ] get to them this january see
where it all started and explored the
iconic origins with historic items
featuring Superman
Captain America Mario Batali Mario who
Super Mario Luigi and the Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles including as always our
monthly t-shirt and pin go to loot crate
calm / burn into my code birth to save
three dollars off any new subscription
today I have no [ __ ] idea what any of
that is I don't know what
to happen there the origins like the
first comic book do you need to explore
the origins of Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles it's it's it's all on the
Internet
Superman that goes back to the 30s there
was no internet back then the internet
came out in the late 60s right when Al
Gore was in his [ __ ] eyes dorm room
right he was in there with Donald Trump
and they are they they both came up with
it they should both host a game show
called what I invented you know it's
like to tell the truth and you gotta
guess right just the two of them just
sit there talking [ __ ] you know I'm
sorry
Dollar Shave Club everybody Jalali shave
club delivers amazing affordable ranges
right to your front door every [ __ ]
months you can get a great shave but
razors aren't the only thing you need in
the bathroom what about all these
showers stuff oh yeah kid you got to
wash your undercarriage you know it's an
old good school thing instead of saying
you need to shave you know those older
guys hey you need you need to take a
shave hey why don't you take a shave
take it shape like a [ __ ] what are you
saying they're [ __ ] grandpa all right
turns out Dollar Shave Club thought of
that I thought of what taking a shave Oh
fine uh-oh shower [ __ ] all right they
just came out with a new line of shower
product shampoo and body wash called the
wanderer where the fragrances are unlike
anything on the market they're subtle
and actually smell like real natural
ingredients there are a lot of body
washes out there that make you smell
like a teenager this mint and cedarwood
body wash is amazing it makes you smell
incredible how is that natural to walk
around smelling like ice cream and like
it just chopped some love up that makes
no [ __ ] sense to me whatsoever
you know what I mean I know mint in
cedar wood exists in nature you got to
give it a try once you're in the club
you'll see the products work amazingly
the surface is world-class and you're
gonna smell like a hummingbird's taint
there's no long term commitments no
hidden fees and your cancer you can
cancel whenever you want then best of
all they give
giving away a one-month trial of any
razor for a dollar with free shipping
that's not really give away if you're
giving it away you're giving it away you
don't ask people for money after that
it's just a few bucks a month get your
$1 trial at dollarshaveclub.com / /
that's dollarshaveclub.com / / and
lastly but not leastly thank [ __ ] god
here stamps stamps com1 great resolution
you can make for the new year
maximize every minute and every dollar
for your small business I know an easy
way to do that I'm gonna read this like
a creepy cult leader trying to get your
money and gradually bring into the fold
I know an easy way to do that with
stamps calm think about how much time
you've wasted how much time you've
wasted going to the post office driving
there finding parking spending your own
money on things that you want to spend
it on I think it's time you came into my
compound and started spending your money
on me because I am truly the Son of God
and not only that stamps.com is the
better way to get posted just use what
you already have you don't need to go
cuz you're already there your computer
and printer - yeah I in with the [ __ ]
truck just use whatever you have all
right you're [ __ ] use your computer
your printer get official US postage for
any letter or package then the mailman
picks it up with stamps calm everything
you do with the post-office you write
from your desk and at a fraction of the
cost one of those expensive postage
meter I use stamps coms whenever I'm
sending out my posters I'm a [ __ ]
[ __ ] if I could figure it out so can
you so right now sign up for stamps calm
and use my code Barbie you are are for
this special offer for week trial plus
$110 bonus offer that includes postage
and a digital scale alright don't wait
go to stamps calm before you do anything
else you click on the microphone at the
top of the homepage you type in bur that
stamps.com enter ber stamps calm never
go to the goddamn [ __ ] post office
again all right let's do the reads for
this week and then I'll get the fall guy
II all right I already read the anger 1
goodwill hey Bill bill loved the podcast
can't wait for f is for family season -
thank you very much last week on the
Thursday podcast you talked about
goodwill I worked at goodwill for a
little over a year and you wouldn't
believe the [ __ ] that was donated there
oh my god this fascinates the hell out
of me I imagine they give you basically
everything short of a body you are
totally right they just throw all this
[ __ ] in trucks but they but instead of
throwing [ __ ] in the oceans wait a
second but they instead of throwing [ __ ]
in the oceans put the trucks in
warehouses and let them set for at least
three to ten years so the [ __ ] can get a
lovely scent of mold over them when they
get loaded they literally throw this
[ __ ] on the truck nine times out of ten
breaking whatever you are donating no
way you know what the [ __ ] you know what
the [ __ ] thing is about donating to
Goodwill you can bring [ __ ] with mold
piss [ __ ] or anything else disgusting
there and they have to take it well then
what are they supposed to do with it I'd
put it on a truck - nine times out of
ten they will take anything but that one
time out of ten if you [ __ ] and
threaten to call corporate and complain
they will take no matter they'll take it
no matter what
oh god somebody's got to do a
documentary on goodwill when I was there
people would donate trash they didn't
want to pay to get rid of couches torn -
[ __ ] with piss stains all over it
mattresses with literal [ __ ] on them and
a laundry list of live long gross [ __ ]
dude this is like an expose and I'm
taking this all as fact I have no idea
if this is true or not they will
literally sell anything I got to the
point that when people would donate
things that were really nice I would
tell them they should keep it or give it
to someone because it would just be
thrown away but of course the
mouth-breathing [ __ ] that would
donate trash that they that they have to
what but of course the mothering
[ __ ] that would donate trash that
they have to take
dude you're a bit of a mouth breather
here you you're not speaking in full
sentences these people are hoarders that
you can't even open their car door
without [ __ ] falling all over the
[ __ ] place
[ __ ] discussing the grossest thing
that I ever saw get sold was it either a
mattress with [ __ ] and piss stains on it
or an antique dildo that had white hair
all over it ah come on come on come on
people I I can't believe this this is
I'm am I getting trolled here is this a
millennial is he giving me the business
he says I know this is going to sound
like I am making myself in this situate
I know this is going to sound like I am
making myself in this situation the good
guy this is a voice text but I seriously
would look at them and be like why the
[ __ ] are we selling this this is really
wrong they will respond with we have to
sell everything to try and make bonus
the sad thing was we never made bonus I
got to the point where I wouldn't price
[ __ ] because it was garbage on my last
day I felt like grabbing a trash bag
from the office go around the building
picking up trash then tying it tie it up
slap a dollar on it and right on the bag
mystery bag or some [ __ ] like that and
see if anybody would buy it but I didn't
dude this is all that was all one
sentence on my last day I felt like
grabbing a trash bag from the office go
around the building picking up trash
then tie it up slap a dollar on it and
right on the bag mystery bag or some
[ __ ] like that and see if someone would
buy it but I didn't on one sentence
thanks bill for the laughs and good luck
to you and Neil with the new baby yeah I
kind of I kind of get but people just
use goodwill because they want to feel
like they're being environmentally
conscious you know I'm not throwing this
out it's going to end up in a landfill
or in the ocean and then you just bring
it down there and they just throw it out
yeah well they didn't take a genius
you'd come down there there's a giant
[ __ ] 18-wheeler empty just parked
there now like it's dropping off or
picking up [ __ ] it's it's it's there on
its own its legs there's no
tractor-trailer there and you know they
just come over there like once a day and
just drive that thing
where is it going all right drama queen
dad dear Billy red-nosed first off I'd
like to say thanks man thank you thank
you I'm a lady oh my god I have a female
fan in high school and lately I've been
listening to your podcast whenever I'm
stressed out or just looking for
something to laugh at
okay now on to the story my father is a
middle-aged man with bipolar disorder
he likes to blame everything on his
mental illness as he calls it I like
that you're already taking him to task
he's gonna blame everything on his
mental illness yes there's no reason to
not do your dishes all right all right
they'll loopy he's very dramatic and
claims that his bipolar is the reason he
hasn't been able to hold a job lately
even though he kept the same career for
about 10 years and is now working for a
new company my parents are divorced so
whenever my father can't have us over to
visit he claims it's because of his
illness man that's the greatest that
there's nothing like a [ __ ] built-in
excuse that's gonna be great when I have
a kid here in a few [ __ ] days minutes
weeks whatever you know I'd love to get
my kid my kids yeah I can't I got a kid
I don't want to tell him him that
bipolar disorder is not a mental illness
because he he'd go apeshit on it he's by
people I don't know I thought any time
your brain was [ __ ] up you had a
mental illness
I haven't mental illness with my anger
okay bipolar bipolar is it a disease
well let's see here oh just give me the
[ __ ] answer
oh Jesus
[ __ ] you I'm not reading all this [ __ ]
this is the Internet I don't want to
expound it all just give me yes or no is
there yes or no calm can you just do
that just answer a few ask of [ __ ]
it's like I don't want to know why is
this blah blah blah yes or no then you
have your answer so then when you go to
the bar and somebody says something like
now
is it or yes it is yaar it is did you
know that bipolar disorder develops with
during a person's late teens or early
adult years do you know I didn't ask
that question
never trust a [ __ ] doctor with a
goatee where the [ __ ] is you know oh my
god
Jesus Christ look at these [ __ ] head
heads he all got a nice full heads of
hair though I gotta give him that
alright anyways I don't want to tell him
bipolar disorder is not a mental illness
because he'll go apeshit on me for some
reason he seems to enjoy making me my
sister feel like [ __ ] it makes mountains
out of molehills whenever we correct him
or stand up for ourselves when he
bullies us yeah I don't take any [ __ ]
you sound like an [ __ ] what's even
worse about this is that his bullying
always works
he's very manipulative and I'm scared to
see him because of the things he said
and done to me in the past
every time I'm I'm informed I'll have to
spend the weekend with him I nearly
pissed myself with anxiety my question
to you is how the [ __ ] do you deal with
someone like this I know my dad is
ridiculous and uses underhanded tactics
tactics to make me feel like [ __ ] but
for some reason I'm not able to just get
over it none of my friends seem to
relate to being so terrified of one
person like I am of my father and I
would like to hear your take on things
thanks for reading this and go [ __ ]
yourself alright how would I get passes
well this is the hardest thing to do you
have to stop giving a [ __ ] about the guy
to a certain level at some point you
know when if you have a parent like this
you have to look at them and remove
mentally that they're a relative and you
have to just say to yourself like if
this person was a complete stranger
would I be friends with this person
would I interact with this person would
I waste another minute my [ __ ] life
dealing with this person you know and
when you got to ask those questions
usually it's like absolutely not this
would have been a [ __ ] one in done
situation but the thing is is is your
dad so you can't write them off but you
have to kind of that's the toughest
thing when you got to write off a parent
but still interact with them you just
got to be like
I don't know you kind of have to find
the humor in it I think that's a tough
one especially at your age I don't know
I would just I don't know I would
probably could do some
passive-aggressive [ __ ] where I would
just say well yeah is that how it is
okay I'll get right on that you know
[ __ ] like that I don't know what to tell
you I would just basically I would still
like what is he gonna do other than get
mad he doesn't doesn't sound like he
hits you anything so he just man and he
flips out or whatever and just I stop
who gives a [ __ ] that's what he's gonna
do the guy's out of his [ __ ] mind
right maybe he's got bipolar maybe
doesn't maybe it's a disease maybe it
isn't all you know just oh man this is
time this is it's fun this is a [ __ ]
rough one
cuz it's your dad and the last thing you
want to do is then go out in the world
and start dating somebody who then
treats you like that that the exact
[ __ ] thing you don't want and then
you end up with that and then you have
that same nervousness in a [ __ ]
relationship that's all I can say you
know what you got it you're not gonna be
able to fix this guy you got a deal with
them because he is your dad but the big
thing that you can do is in your life is
you create a life that does not involve
this alright you need to go out and go
marry a [ __ ] suite right and then
your [ __ ] house is great and it's
peaceful and it's what you want then
every once in a while this [ __ ] torn
it tornado blows through and you deal
with it and then it leaves and then you
go back to your peaceful life that's all
you can do you really as a kid you
really can't do anything about your
parents you can't pick them you just get
the ones that you get but the thing that
you can do is create a life that does
not involve that and then you don't do
that [ __ ] to your kids and then you
break the cycle then that's it you know
but the weird [ __ ] thing is is that
your your decks still always gonna be in
your life you know so that lunatic will
then be around your kids and it's just
it's it's a [ __ ] it really is
but fortunately they for the most part
die before we do and then you
no you don't have to deal with them
anymore so I guess try to find the
[ __ ] humor in it while you're dealing
with it and then think of how exciting
your life is gonna be by not having that
in it you know you might want to just
Skype with them for a while get yourself
in a situation to be like what I think
the screen froze hello
you just click but that's really that's
disappointing to hear that an adult
would manipulate a teenager forget about
his own [ __ ] daughter that sucks so I
don't try that but just know that you
can go out in the world and have any
life that you want to have simply by you
know you know he's showing you what you
don't want all right there you go
about me that's brutal you [ __ ] you [ __ ]
up so bad as a parent that your daughter
goes out going I want to marry a man
who's the exact opposite of my own dad
booth that's game set match you [ __ ]
up as a father all right sisters
girlfriend dear bill the red [ __ ] burr
my twin sister is a lesbian and she's
dating a lady who was bisexual she was
bisexual and then what then what became
totally homosexual and went back to
heterosexuality or is she a sexual at
first we didn't we weren't close or
anything but we did get along you know
you with your twin sister not the
bisexual woman right then about a year
ago we ran into each other at a club in
the end oh I know you talked about the
bisexually my sister is a lesbian and
she was dating a lady who was bisexual
first we weren't closer or anything but
but we got along I'm assuming you talk
about the bisexual lady then about a
year ago we ran into each other at a
downtown club we we had a few draw Jesus
we have a few drinks just start talking
about random stuff she came back she's
gonna try to the [ __ ] she can try to
[ __ ] the whole family here until a
friend of mine invited us to a party at
some guy's house we went and had a lot
more to drink and then one thing led to
another
what does anything good ever come after
and then you know one thing led to
another
that's when you're fast for
through something a piece-of-shit thing
you did or something you're embarrassed
of it yeah one thing led to another
no one ever talks about [ __ ] hey how
did you hit that one that winning game
shot well they invited the ball and now
one thing led to another and you know I
had to buy a shot to win a championship
you will tell every [ __ ] detail I was
running down the court with every step I
can feel my heart beat I knew somebody
had to step up but I knew that someone
was gonna pay me right that's how you
tell it when you [ __ ] when you did
some good [ __ ] you did you bad [ __ ] yeah
one thing led to another and the guy was
on the ground and he wasn't breathing so
I don't know okay one thing led to
another we ended up having sex the next
day we came we came to and both felt a
horrible about what happened you both
came to I just pictured that [ __ ] you
know take my picture smack my [ __ ]
remember that
Madonna was in the background going on
she was singing like the [ __ ] opening
to Star Trek the next day we came to and
both felt horribly about what happened
she then told my sister that she slept
with the man but didn't tell her it was
me oh wait you're a guy I thought this
was a lady oh okay okay i bisexually I
don't know alright wait a minute wait a
minute alright your twin sister is a
lesbian she's dating the lady's bisexual
yeah yeah first we weren't close for
anything but we got along okay and then
you ran into her and you [ __ ] you
[ __ ] your [ __ ] sister's girlfriend
no wonder you went with one thing led to
another then we came to like you were
both drugged oh these are classic you
feel horrible about this sir or you
don't and but you want to get away with
it so you blowing through the details
what is it very this is very
underwritten for what the [ __ ] has just
gone down here Jesus Christ
she then told my sister that she slept
with a man but didn't tell her it was me
dude this chick is a psycho for the past
year I've been torn up about it
I need your unbiased style of advice
should I tell my sister that was me or
not
Thanks PS come to blah blah blah I would
love to see you again
dude no don't say a few die with that
secret that with that secret and hope
that woman fades away and then if it
ever comes back around she said it was
you and just be like it was I wouldn't
say a [ __ ] word don't say a [ __ ]
word
okay the fly in the ointment here is
this bisexual lady okay she's jumping
all over the fence she's [ __ ] sisters
she's [ __ ] brothers and she's [ __ ]
white people no kidding she's [ __ ]
two people in dead things she's she's
the fly in the [ __ ] ointment okay she
said this [ __ ] I don't know why she's
doing that this is like this is she's
like Glenn Close in fatal attraction if
she [ __ ] both Michael Douglas and the
hottie he was married to and the rabbit
okay just [ __ ] this lady just you know
you just sit tight okay this is like
you're in a sub and you cut the engines
and you're just hoping that they're not
gonna start dropping deaf charges you
just hope you get through it sometimes
in life you just shut the [ __ ] up hi
this is one I wouldn't say anything okay
and if she brings it up yeah you slept
with her I would just I mean what are
you gonna do this is the thing you just
this lady's out of her [ __ ] mind
there's no way your sister's gonna end
up with her okay there's no way she's
gonna end up with her all right this
woman's out of her [ __ ] mind
so she's eventually gonna fade away all
you have to do is just hope that when it
comes time for the breakup that the
crazy [ __ ] is breaking up with your
sister because if your sister goes to
break up with her in that highly
emotional moment she might drop the bomb
okay and then you would just you just
got to play it like she said what
no I never have she's just you were just
breaking up - she said that's why she
was saying it because you're broken that
she walks in the room you're like all
right I did it
[Music]
all right cause my pants down a Billy
blue lungs I don't know what that means
I'm 24 years old and I'm dating a woman
that is 34 years old all right so you
[ __ ] it all the lady you're not
dating come on what do you do well
you're gonna have your first kid with
her when she's like 96 we've been dating
for close to three years now and I
couldn't be happier we recently bought a
house so Jesus you're 24 you date in the
34 year old you bought a house with her
we easily bought a house I would be
nervous if this was flipped and the guy
was 34 it was a 24 year old he's still a
wild horse man you got a run out on the
range we recently bought a house and it
finally came time to put down the down
payment on the house and all that extra
stuff I'm gonna be honest man ego issues
on the down payment
she knows my financial status and she
was cool with it but I just wanted to
provide more because she does so much
for me so I dropped my car insurance
without her knowing to give her the
extra money even though she said I
didn't need to I felt like what sort of
man would I be if I didn't contribute my
part so my luck has it I got into a car
accident literally two weeks after I
dropped my car insurance between a rock
and a hard place now we want to start a
family but I'm guessing my license would
be suspended for a year a lot of burden
will be put upon her now that I am I'm
assuming my license will be suspended
for sometime
bill any if you could do me a solid on
this one that would be great PS longtime
listener first-time email oh Jesus what
do you what are you asking me like yeah
you're [ __ ] you are [ __ ] I agree
with that
well I in life sometimes you learn a
hard lesson sir and you're learning one
right now I'm sorry I don't know what to
tell you you with this woman I mean
the solution you what you learned is the
solution is not doing what you did you
don't expose yourself to that type of a
liability
[Music]
you didn't really ask me a question all
right so you love this person you want
to start a family that's all good and
you [ __ ] up I would I guess if you
haven't told her I would come clean tell
her what you did why you did it say
you're sorry and and I don't know what
you but you're 24 and you want to be
able to provide she's 34 and you're
gonna get married you're gonna start a
family I don't know how you be able to
provide you got to get your career going
I would think so that would be my
biggest concern once I find out what the
judgment against me is going to be but
hey it's a deal dude she's 34 you're 24
she should be making more money than you
she should have more money than you her
life should be further down there you
know you can't try to catch up to a 34
year old alright cuz the only way for
you to do it is to do what you just did
and you end up [ __ ] yourself over and
in the long run you [ __ ] her over too so
you have to respect the fact that you're
the age you're at and I would try to
figure out what the [ __ ] I wanted to do
with my life and I would try to get that
career going and I would hope that there
would be a bus close by that I could
take to get me to that because you're
think you're gonna get [ __ ] here sorry
to say that but yeah my advice would be
to stop trying to measure up to a 34
year old just be 24 alright I hope that
helped you out but that's all I got
sorry okay alright that's the podcast
for this week if you'd like to donate to
the podcast you can always do that
anytime you shop on Amazon well how do I
do that bill well you just go to
billboard.com you click on the podcast
page and there's an amazon link you
click on that takes you right to Amazon
you know it doesn't cost you any extra
money I get credit for driving traffic
to that site Yatta Yatta Yatta up will
do the doodle whatever whatever the [ __ ]
you want to say there alright and they
give me a little bit of money alright
that's it that's it go [ __ ] yourselves
and I'll check in on ya on
congratulations to USC congratulations
to Clemson Alabama
Parnelli we're gonna see who's gonna
[ __ ] win that one and NFL playoffs
playoffs are coming Bruins had a nice
two game win streak over the Sabres and
then we [ __ ] lost yesterday I missed
that game got [ __ ] smoke three to
nothing but who do we play played
[ __ ] the Carolina Hurricanes that's
it hey everybody the holidays are over
it's a brand-new [ __ ] year don't deal
with bipolar people all right if you
gotta make a left
get over towards the double line don't
liquidate your [ __ ] insurance so you
can try to [ __ ] bang a four year old
and I think that's it yeah and if you
bang your lesbian sisters girlfriend
keep your [ __ ] mouth shut all right
talk to you on Thursday